butI got back my booty got back and my
ass got crack that's a terrible song hey
what is going on YouTube now
interestingly enough I'm a pretty open
guy right when it comes to like talking
freely about my life the things that
I've experienced oh burpee like I'm
pretty good with it I'm an open book
I'm the type of person if I walked out
in the middle street and somebody say
some [ __ ] like yo I heard somebody say
some [ __ ] about you I would be like yeah
it's true I sucked a lot of dick but on
today subscriber ask questions you guys
are gonna get a [ __ ] a funny story
out of this recently a subscriber asked
hey Davis so I've been with my girl for
quite a while now and every time we have
sex she says she doesn't feel excited
what she asks of me is that I talk dirty
to her I don't know how to do it
have you ever done it before talking
dirty while you have sex is such an
interesting experience number one before
I even get into this I'm not that I'm
not like this prolific you know sex talk
guy is not my thing I would never that
sexually active when I was younger I
didn't have a lot of opportunities so
you're not really getting this
perspective from a dude that has [ __ ]
a lot of different women in there number
one when I think when you have like that
dirty talking give that super type of
excitement because you kind of step out
of yourself it's not usually who you are
it's not usually the personality that
you have but for some reason when you
try to give it turns you into a
different beast and that's probably what
your girlfriend wants she wants you to
be not David but she wants you to be the
lead I poppies get in there and there's
at the same time Mary I'm not saying
that's what you grow up it sounds like
but is she the honest I'm sorry she does
know but let me tell you the first time
I ever tried to dirty talk one of the
girls that I was with so there was this
girl that I dated and she was somebody
that was outside of the normal type of
girls I date now the people that I like
to be with other people that I had been
in a relationship with are people who
are very quirky they have some weird
personality they have something that
makes me laugh this girl had absolutely
she was attractive she was super cute
the first time I met her was at a
Halloween party she was running this
naughty nun outfit I had a boner and
then she was like what's that I put a
towel over it I was like I guess what
I'm Pinocchio but little did I know
through her previous sexual partners
that during sex she liked it when people
said some [ __ ] weird [ __ ] to her I
wasn't used to it I never dirty talked
before it's not in my nature could you
imagine me doing that [ __ ] yeah you like
down here here yeah so this is a girl
that I was with for I say roughly about
maybe a couple of months she and I were
in a quote/unquote serious relationship
so you know sex was on the table who
knows something that she really liked
doing now when that dirty sex talk
things started coming up that [ __ ] threw
me off so one night we were in bed get
hot she's on top of me and then she says
talk dirty to me poppy number one I
don't know who she was talking to
because she called me a father out
besides what you this is weird but you
know poppy is what some girls say you
know I beat you as a turkey time but
yeah I started getting into it and it
was getting a little fun it was a world
I haven't really tapped into yet so she
was asking me a couple of questions yeah
you like this [ __ ] that kind of came
back with the yeah baby I love bear she
tried try not to throw up yet and so it
was normal it was good and then she
threw a question that me that was kind
of a curveball she goes yeah baby whose
[ __ ] is this and you know what I said
uh yours ah uh she asked me whose [ __ ]
is this and I told her oh it's yours
ah he's one of those things that every
time I tell the story I [ __ ] cringe
because I was caught off guard I had no
idea what the [ __ ] who whose [ __ ] it's
your loss is it it's not mine but
apparently that's the answer that she
wanted because after I said that she
looked at me she gets up and she goes
are you [ __ ] serious what the [ __ ] I
didn't know it was a surprise multiple
choice question day I thought we were
just gonna get it on your thing at the
accident day what I tell you is that if
your girl wants to try new things in bed
and she wants you to talk a little dirty
to her don't don't worry about it no
matter what you do you're not gonna do
something as bad as I did I I literally
said yours with a question mark that's
the thing about it when you intimate
with your partner in my personal
opinion it's about feeling it out and
it's kind of dope that she is asking you
to do things because on your part you
don't have to figure out what she wants
this is something that she verbally told
you so you just have to be strong enough
and experimental enough to try it out
and if it feels weird don't worry you'll
get over it and I'm pretty sure she's
vocal enough to let you know these
things she'll probably tell you what she
does like and doesn't like in the future
you know what the wid thing was if
dirty-talking wasn't even the only thing
she liked she liked all that like rough
[ __ ] like she wanted me to like ghetto a
belt and choke her out with it and then
she actually asked me to slap her once
and I couldn't do it like it is not my
thing it's like [ __ ] you want to [ __ ]
or you want a box what's going on oh
yeah tell me I have AIDS what
yours really yours